[Musique]
bonsoir à tous au salon de l'agriculture
aujourd'hui le concours inter régions
débouchés vous le voyez beaucoup de
monde qui regarde et puis à l'intérieur
de l'espace des couteau bien aiguisé de
l'avion en train d'être découpée et
surtout une équipe de la région de
bourgogne avec un apprenti un boucher
une bouchère ils sont juste là où son
fils ils ont l'air de très bien se
débrouiller on va aller voir
[Musique]
premières minutes de concours est déjà
un problème pour l'équipe bourguignonne
une pièce de viande se fait attendre
j'ai eu un petit souci je vais pas du
tout de suite bon c'est pas grave on va
rattraper le temps perdu
quatre heures de travail pour cette
équipe constituée spécialement pour le
salon florence et sébastien les deux
bouchers et florian l'apprenti
bah ya du monde c'est au salon de
l'agriculture première proc
que j'ai au salon
autant de participants
c'était en tant que non jamais
en premier une grande première
première spéciale
les préparations avance les plateaux se
remplissent sous les yeux de l'équipe de
france déboucher un jury attentif au
moindre détail des au sein du milieu de
pins dans le but de le vent des côtes de
boeuf
choses et nous en tant que meilleur
ouvrier de france et membre de l'équipe
de france dont on est là vous me
conseiller ben c'est jeune pour qu'il
puisse avancer dans dans le métier et
surtout leur donner l'envié de faire ces
concours comme
pour elle le fait si
je voulais pas d'avoir si oui bon alors
je soutiens servi parce que lui mais
commence à se redresser au couteau
serait la soeur sa troisième édition
connu pour offrir une bonne coopération
à l'arrivée ce plateau de viande et une
sixième place pour cette équipe qui a
obtenu un prix spécial pour sa
préparation de l'année
gfr
[Musique]
alors dans la région on connaît bien sûr
la race locale le mouton charollais mais
ya pas que ça il ya aussi des moutons
qui viennent d'autres pays d'autres
races c'est le cas de ces races anglaise
on avec baptiste foyot bonjour c'est
quoi cette race alors c'est une race
anglaise qui s'appelle la soodhun vous
avez une autre race anglaise si nous
nous élevons aussi déçu folle et là on a
aussi le mouton charollais dans la
résine pourquoi pas prendre cette race
là alors historiquement mon grand père
avait toujours eu des secondes sur
l'exploitation donc pour conserver la
race mon père a
et d'arguer cet élevage et je vois vous
avez des très belles médailles qu'est ce
que vous avez gagné oui alors et hier
c'était le concours de la race nous
avons remporté les premiers prix de
chaque catégorie pour emmener ses belles
médailles chez nous puis les exposer
dans notre
nos bergerie à merci beaucoup merci à
vous
[Musique]
c'est une petite boutique rue de la
convention dans le 15e arrondissement
mais pour les amateurs de bollywood fois
c'est la caverne d'ali baba puisque
françois l'europe propose depuis 12 ans
tout ce que la franche comté fait de
meilleur
on prend du coup prêt pour un week-end
non un 12 mois de ça voilà
à la base il y a le fromage la
charcuterie et le chardonnay cette
cliente fournit son entreprise pour le
pouls du vendredi soir le contenu on
prend l'apéritif
de chez monsieur et je me suis habitué
et ses délicieux donc je vienne
achalandée pour mon week end à moi
on a pris en compte leurs athlètes en
fait monsieur choisir pour nous donc à
chaque fois c'est la surprise les
produisent sont extra c'est pas très
cher qui on aime beaucoup à 10 euros la
saucisse de morteau et 30 euros le kilo
de compter 18 mois françois le rhône la
somme pas les chalands parisien alcool
limonade épicerie salée et sucrée le
natif du russe et renouvelle sa boutique
en permanence avant j'avais une
brasserie je travaille déjà avec
certains fournisseurs
puis après j'ai rajouté quelques petites
choses parce que la franche comté c'est
aussi le pontarlier s'est aussi
l'absinthe l'histoire de l'absinthe les
gens adorent qu'on leur raconte parce
que innovate pour eux ça n'existe
toujours pas donc là c'est un vrai
plaisir puis après je retourne
régulièrement voir des gens des
producteurs voir si ça peut marcher si
le magasin est petit il attire l'oeil
depuis de françois le roux a ouvert la
devanture en grand et changer son
intitulé la chose la plus importante qui
vient a fait vraiment le développement
de la boutique c'est le fait d'avoir mis
saucisse de morteau est compté les
parisiens ne savent pas où se trouve la
franche comté mais par contre depuis que
je suis là et a beaucoup de mes clients
qui sont partis en franche comté et ça
c'est un point positif
alors je pense que je suis un bon
ambassadeur de la franche comté
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui demain ne
seront entre autres au salon du fromage
pour parler des productions de la
franche comté et de la bourgogne 2 leurs
nouveautés bonne soirée